[Music]
no and welcome to this video in this
video we'll be looking at the sidelines
that white may play against the Rogozin
so going to
which with the starting position of them
wins gambit recursion after Bishop
before and now check what else White has
available we already have looked at to
the caption in a dedicated chapter and
the check in the autumn and Bishop g5
and in this chapter we will base a claim
deal with the rest there are actually
many possible trends positions from this
position into nimzo-indian lines lines
that we deal with homonyms winning
starting move autumn besides those most
things are rather harmless there's only
one particular line that is Queen to b3
that is all from young over a particular
theoretical interest but we have to
check the other moves so let's have a
look at some that will be sorry just a
transpose and the move G is real-world
transpose we just Castle and reach a
position that we can get from various
move waters from a Catalan with Bishop
before Czech Knight c3 or from the
nimzo-indian with for g3 so this is not
dealt with in this video and this
chapter not very frequently seen move
anyway um
a move that looks fairly normal but it's
also unusual in this particular
situation is Queen c2 means the two is
quite often seen as a response to Bishop
before but here we have an immediate
counter play in the center with c5 and
now it's not quite clear what White's ya
would white is supposed to do that makes
any sense why it certainly doesn't want
to take on on d5 that looks completely
harmless but what is he supposed to do
if he plays III that looks like a weird
hybrid of them
III NIMS over Ben Steinem so on and the
classical names or so that is also not
very dangerous we can look at those two
moves just to show so here we will
simply recapture and have a very active
position one line that is possible is
Bishop g5
take stakes 96 and we are rapidly
developing it's not even as that easily
imaginable how white is not going to
take on c6 now III is also very meek
move so something like this is very
young very easy to play we have active
pieces you have a half-open be found no
problem at all um white may also play
III which is as mentioned a bit of a an
odd hybrid of nimzo-indian type play the
Queen is on C this was a free preview of
our entire one d4 course based on the
nimzo-indian end recording available on
chasuble com thanks for watching and see
you soon
[Music]